come let me clutch thee are these two
words clutch thee alright so today I'm
gonna be playing a game where I have to
determine whether or not someone's drunk
or sober and if I win I get to go home
with a bottle of champagne I definitely
think I'm a good judge if someone is
drunk or sober yeah I think I have a
pretty solid eye for knowing when
someone's kind of messed up or not been
there I've been sober and drunk I think
I can figure it out am i any good at
identifying someone's drunk or sober I'm
sober I think I'm great at it when I'm
drunk I just think everyone's drunk I
think I can pick them out there's some
good towels just using my nose you can
probably smell someone's breath and find
the alcohol and that I just found out
that if I win I get a bottle of
champagne so I'm definitely if not now
at some point gonna be the drunk
[Music]
give me my robe put on my crown
I have immortal longings in me no more
the juice of egypt's grapes show boys
this lip yep your yard yeah good iris
quick methinks I hear Antony call my
other elements I give to base base our
life so have you done have you done but
soft what light through yonder window
breaks it is the east and Juliet is the
Sun arise fair Sun and kill the envious
moon o that she knew she weren't see how
she leans her cheek upon her hand oh
that I were a glove upon that hand that
I might touch that cheek do you study
Shakespeare no that's really excellent
thank you
I moved I was moved Andrew seems quite
intrigued hear him read next very into
both of the people mine looks a lot
longer is this a dagger which I see
before me the hand the handle toward my
hand come let me clutch thee are these
two words clutch thee it's written as
one word clutching what's B I have thee
not and yet I see thee still as this
which not now I draw oh my god while
sigh thread he lives words to the heats
of beads to cold breath gives ok I
couldn't tell if Andrew had a hard time
like with the text or just like reading
in general so I don't know if you I
didn't know if he was drinking uh
reading was tricky sometimes I get it
with both of you it's like it's that
drunk confidence where they went after
it and then Colley and she she was just
a little hesitant but then she got in
there and got a little stumble II but I
don't know if she was putting that on
cuz she's a good actor in movies my mind
says it like this is all
like Andrews 100% in action something
about Sam's like focus on the text but
like having the struggle staying in
place kind of leads me towards Sam being
maybe yeah what is your relationship
like with your dad my dad's dead okay
yelling good for the most part all dads
are incredibly flawed and as far as like
a flawed dude student all right I don't
have a good story about dad that would
fit into video my grandmother raised me
on her own so she's mom and dad so solid
written by dad so I meet your question
what it kind of drinks do y'all usually
drink if you are out I like a vodka
martini better Sam I love IPAs those are
going my greatest but not sweet
so like when was like the last time you
drank to like where you don't remember
what was the last time you black out
blacked out from drinking oh my
going-away party when I left here two
years ago yeah everyone was just I was
like I had so many drinks I don't know
what to do with them they carried me out
and I puked in front of the place I'll
go with that as well I had a going-away
party leaving San Francisco and I got a
really I did a show and I got very drunk
and then we went to a karaoke bar and my
boyfriend and I attempted to dance and
well I ended up injured but yeah I don't
remember time of what happened that
night Christmas no near Christmas it's
probably pursue such a sin is like after
he picks me from the airport and I went
to a bar I was like oh but I don't know
I don't know if that's for sure if I
definitely lost time that's that's what
blacking out it I'm pleased to know that
these were like kind of recently I still
think Andrews drunk
okay I've completely moved over to
Colleen being dressed
no I'm right between them my just
walking problem
I got balance for days he just got red
all up in the face well this part is
harder than I imagined playing tricks on
me now I'm going to do this swiftness
call she said wow I don't know that's
like drunk luck like blind sprinting
let's put this egg maybe they're all
drunk I'm pretty sure it's Andrew and if
I'm mistaken then you're just like a
jovial man and like you're such a nice
guy but I just think that he is drunk
for he talking a lot he's yeah he talks
a lot he just can't quite contain
himself he's just a little fidgety maybe
I'm really gullible or I'm really
gullible we miss is all an act I just
have to I'm gonna go with my gut let me
go Sam calling he keeps breaking eye
contact every time I've like tried to
make eye contact
Sam is giving me like hard like I'm
focused on you eyes to me to me it's
like I've noticed the small details when
she was doing like the wine walk she was
like purposely pulling her heels back so
she could follow the heel to toe rule a
lot of small things that are like weird
adjustments that makes me think she is
the one who has been drinking
oh my god she pays are good what were
you thinking oh god yeah I had a boxed
wine that was like this big yeah three
glasses in it and then I had a little
bit of rum and look right Wow all right
this is my first drink I'm seeing rich
between two people doing honest work and
I am just about to get drunk midday on a
Monday let's do it it's my thank you
that's what you're gonna get a roll Mo's
of grape Apple and citrus mm-hmm and
plastic it gets better it gets better my
mom should be very proud I'm very proud
all right guys I've been promoted after
finishing the wine cube
- a little lip right and a little round
bad decisions in a good time get there
the rum and Pina look right so I think
I'm good done tight lately in the Kula
sense
should I get bangs that seems like the
question that rules my life I'm thinking
yeah
[Music]